a tragic passing a secret wedding and
one last heartbreaking phone call here's
what went down in the final conversation
between Ryan coogler and The Chadwick
Boseman the release of black panther
wakanda forever is sure to be one of the
most emotional outings in the MCU so far
the original film was a massive success
for the franchise earning over 1.3
billion dollars worldwide and almost
guaranteeing a sequel in the process
confirmation of a second movie came in
October 2018 with The Hollywood Reporter
noting that Ryan coogler had signed a
deal to direct and write the second film
thr also noted around that time that
Chadwick Boseman was negotiating a deal
for 10 million dollars for the sequel
and 20 million dollars for a third black
panther film so much has changed in the
years since the sequel was given the go
with the MCU fandom still reeling from
the loss of Bozeman who died of colon
cancer in 2020. these emotions are sure
to come flooding back in with the
release of wakanda forever which will
deal with the aftermath of King
t'challa's death Ryan coogler had a lot
on his plate with handling the sequel
the director recently appeared on an
episode of wakanda forever the official
black panther podcast to discuss the
upcoming film at length Boseman is at
the heart of the discussion of course
and Kugler even recounts their last
phone call when author and host tanahasi
Coates asked Kugler when he finished
writing the script for wakanda forever
Kugler amitzi was done with it before
Chadwick Boseman passed which obviously
prompted a major rewrite code
subsequently asked for Bozeman said when
coogler called him to see if he wanted
to read the script after a long silence
Kugler says he was tired bro
oh I could tell he was tired coogler
says that he had been trying to get a
hold of Bozeman for a few days before
they finally connected for what would be
their last phone call referring to
Bozeman's wife Simone ledward coogler
said he kicked someone out because he
told her he didn't want her to hear
nothing that could that could get him in
trouble with his NDA Google ads and she
didn't want to leave him
so I could so I could tell her something
was up coogler says that Bozeman and
ledward were planning their wedding in
South Carolina according to US Weekly
The Duo wed just a few months before
Bozeman died Bozeman then asked hugler
about his child as he had missed the
baby shower that had just been held
after talking about weddings and
children Ryan coogler and Chadwick
boseman's conversation moved on to the
Black Panther sequel according to Kugler
Bozeman said he didn't want to read the
finished scripts because he didn't want
to get in the way of any notes the
studio might have so he said he would
read it after they did the director
later found out that Bozeman couldn't
read the scripts because he was just too
tired goats then asked how soon after
the phone call Bozeman died a couple
weeks
EMA a couple weeks
cougars manager and agent called and
told him but he didn't believe it at
first so he called Denzel Washington to
check if it was true he then texted
Bozeman hoping it was a rumor shortly
after the official press release went
live and a nightmare became reality
[Music]